[Music]
thank you
hello and welcome to the week in 60
minutes brought to you by spectator TV
I'm Katie balls The Spectators political
editor
coming up on the show
who you break Britain that's the
question okay Andrews tries to answer in
this week's cover
and she'll be appearing on the show of
Hamish McRae
the Texan Supreme Court has just upheld
a law to ban the use of so-called gender
affirming care Lionel Shriver will be on
the show to explain
it's one year since Liz truss became
prime minister we'll be thinking about
the highs and the lows for James Hill
her biographer
John Kiger writes in this week's
magazine about the collapse of Franco
freak he'll be on with Jonathan
Griffin's Mazer to tell us what went
wrong for France
a year on from the Queen's death how has
the royal family changed Robert Hardman
will be on the show and finally former
MP Chris Mullins reviews Rory Stewart's
Memoir in this week's magazine
will Stewart make a return to Frontline
politics Chris joins me to discuss
first up schools are crumbling NHS
waiting lists are millions long and
trains never seem to run on time what
happened to Britain Kate Andrews writes
this week's cover broken Britain and she
joins me now alongside the economist
Hamish McRae
Kate Hamish thank you for joining
spectator TV this week Kate you write
about broken Britain in your cover piece
why is Britain broken
well the popular narrative is that it
was the Tory cuts the years of austerity
that every problem we can point to now
crumbling concrete can't see your GP
roads aren't fixed up airports and Chaos
rail systems not working fundamentally
comes down to those years of cuts and
this week's cover piece takes a slightly
different perspective it looks at those
cuts but it notes that fundamentally we
are spending more and taxing more than
essentially ever before not ever before
but taxes are at a record 70-year high
getting close to it we're spending more
than Tony Blair was spending Gordon
Brown was spending money is not the
issue there's so much money being
funneled into the treasury and being
funneled back out it's not so much a
question of spending cuts but where
those cuts were performed and what was
prioritized and the piece goes back into
the brown years into the Cameron and
Osborne years and talks mainly about
Capital spending the fact that it's
really easy to cut Capital spending
because you can just about keep it going
for quite a long period of time you
won't notice that the roof's about to
cave in for a long time you won't notice
that things are breaking down until you
have an issue like we had this week with
schools where actually the the parents
of 150 schools their children were told
that they couldn't return because it was
too dangerous
um so what what rounded what brown
planned to do and what Cameron
implemented was that chipping away at
the capital budgets so that they could
pour the money into things like Health
pensions and Welfare the politically
sensitive and popular areas that people
always want more money for it's
essentially short-termism at its worst
because it's it's bribing voters not
telling them about the Investments that
need to be made down the road and the
irony as I point out in the piece is
that I think a lot of these politicians
probably thought well I'll be long gone
by the time that these things start to
break down and that's somewhat true but
the Tory government is still here and 13
years on Rishi sunak is having to
explain why these decisions were made
more than a decade ago because the
Tories are still in charge and had they
done some of those crucial Investments
and reprioritized funding and had
tougher conversations with the public
then where she's seen that could in
theory be taking credit right now for
new infrastructure programs for better
schools instead he's having to defend
why the country's falling apart and what
do you think about that Central argument
from Kate which is effectively
short-term spending is prioritized over
long-term spending by a success of
governments uh partly because of the
election cycle and so forth do you think
that's the big problem here I I think
it's the piece is spot on uh you know
it's great that you should be on the
cover so you know you you've got a
winner there
um
I think I would take the thing back even
further this idea that you can always
cut the capital budget but it's very
very tough politically to cut the car
goes back to oh my gosh the 60s the 50s
you know
um maybe not the 50s the 50s we did
spend a lot of capital budget on
building homes that you know public
housing they had to be pulled down 20 25
years later
um but but a lot of these schools were
built in the 50s and 60s and there was
money there for Capital just we spent
that Capital very badly we cut Corners
um and I think if you look at one of the
big Arguments for privatization was that
actually if private companies were doing
the investment it wouldn't be cut back
every time there was a crisis and the
treasury said we got no money and and in
some sense
um I I'd cut I'd cut us a bit more slack
I mean some things have worked
um we didn't do didn't do the railways
well but actually double the number of
people are traveling on Railways now
than they were when they were before
they were privatized I think that's a
bigger increase than in any developed
country in the world I stand to be
corrected on that one but I I can't find
one quickly so I think we should should
recognize that this this is an old
problem and it's a recurring old problem
and the next question is how do we fix
it
that is such an important point because
water is a really good example right now
a lot of people argue well there just
hasn't been enough investment in water
infrastructure it needs to be taken back
into the public sector and you know my
big question with that is investment
certainly has gone up since water was
privatized but more than that if water
were brought back into the public sector
are you really trying to tell me that we
would start diverting money from the NHS
and day-to-day spending on doctors and
nurses salaries to invest in water
infrastructure there's no way that that
would happen so by no means would I
argue that you know this should all be
in the hands of the state and they
should just be more efficient and they
should be more efficient that's a
separate point but that they should just
this is just a simple issue that the
state didn't prioritize properly the
private sector has such an important
role and an accountable role to play
here too but in the areas where actually
we have we now should have been talking
about reform for a very long time
pensions welfare the NHS
the Tory government in particular has
been so hesitant to do that
Tony Blair was better at NHS reform than
any of the Tory prime ministers have
been and there are political reasons for
that but the situation we now find
ourselves in is between the Department
of Health and department for work and
pensions roughly and you can pretty much
slot the money into those two
departments
um they account for 40 of public
spending and that number's only going to
increase because the demands around
changing demographics around Health Care
around welfare around aging are going to
demand more money so long as you don't
touch that and you won't talk about that
do not expect tons of new schools to be
built do not expect amazing upgrades
because there's a lot of money and it's
being funneled into very particular
areas yeah I think I think following
that through we've got to segment you
know there is a national health uh
problem you know how do we how do we
fund that there is a how do we build
schools problem there is a um what's
gone wrong with water problem
um there's a what do we do with so I I
why aren't we building enough rooms like
it's all broken so I think you've got
you've got to segment yeah why aren't we
building more homes that goes back to
the 47 Town and Country planning acts
you know so I mean I think you've got to
when we say everything is is going bad
but I think we've got to say lots of
little things are all going badly and
there are lots of sorry gotta step back
lots of pretty big things are going
badly but we ought to recognize where
we've had reasonable success stories uh
and if you want one I mean I think I
would cite
I was citing a port Savannah a sad thing
to say now but if you look London more
people fly obviously they did before the
pandemic in and out of London six
airports that any other place on Earth
and they'd by and large got in and got
out all right and it wasn't very
expensive I think that that we we don't
celebrate that we don't realize that
actually pretty pretty darn difficult to
get all those people in and all out
without all the plans of course we did
just have air traffic control so some
people who recently been at airports may
have a different view of an airport just
in their immediate memory um but then I
do wonder you are being an absolute ray
of light on today's segment and quite
optimistic so I'll cover I'll do some
Shameless advertising broken Britain do
you think it's a bit too negative
well
I think it's a bit broken many many
years ago I used to edit a new a
magazine and I think is a great cup so
get that one out of the way uh
really diplomatic answer I think I do
think that we should be very careful in
criticizing things that have gone wrong
and actually this was implicit on your
point about water
um uh not to try and think there's a
simple solution and that everything is
terrible the case of water the reason it
was privatized was
um the public sector wasn't it it wasn't
putting it enough money and quite a bit
more money was put in by the private
sector there Villas had a very bad
control system they all ripped it all
out but but I mean I do think a lot of
investment has taken place and the
London the London ring May
um so I think that
I would like to see
us and maybe your readers will cut a
little bit of slack for governments for
for the country if not for this
government or even more so for previous
governments I you know I I do say in the
piece that and in normal times although
what are normal times these days but you
can imagine a world where if this were
the main crisis it would be very bad but
also considered manageable people would
say schools schools yeah because it's
about one percent of current schools
that have wrecked exactly and even if
that number goes up and we expect that
it might um even if it went up by
several hundred you would be able to say
look this is a terrible situation A
Dangerous situation we can manage it the
problem is that you are managing that on
top of a 7.6 million waiting list on the
NHS you are managing that on top of an
economy that it turns out actually grew
much faster than we originally thought
but is still rather stagnant and really
not developing your your challenge
you're dealing with this on top of a
productivity crisis you're dealing with
this on top of so many things that
people feel are going wrong and I think
you know to turn this to the politics
slightly one of the problems that the
Tory government has is even if I you
know I think it could be generally
accepted that this particular set of
politicians is not responsible for the
concrete crisis but if you put to people
do you feel like things are working
you know everyone will have something to
point to to say no and I think that's
the problem is that these these crises
these scandals build up and something
that could have been manageable all of a
sudden seems like it's not because it is
on top of something else so to end the
segment to you both
um well I suppose starting new games
what do you think when we talk about how
to fix many of these problems or you
know going into an election year
potentially a regime change of the polls
are ending to go by
um what are the lessons we need to learn
from can putting off these kind of
long-term Solutions I think the I think
the big lesson for politicians is going
to be very difficult to be a politician
in any Western economy over the next 15
years because there will be no money for
any of them aging populations everywhere
UK actually aging slightly slower than
than most countries and and population
Rising here whereas she falling so this
is going to be a bad time to be a
politician whose message is we can fix
it I think therefore what clever
politicians will do is to say we can fix
this and this this is our our job
um what we can't fix is that and that
and we are having other agencies and
other centers of power to do that just
as in the early 90s politicians said we
are not doing very well at controlling
inflation setting interest rates and
round the world uh central banks were
given that task to run monetary policy
and I think something like that sort of
switch where polishing to have to say
we're not doing well let's figure out
another way of doing it and we will do
what we can do well we've got other
people who do those other things I think
something like that will happen in a lot
of areas
um including things like um
schools and probably the NHS that's a
strong case for a royal commission for
the NHS actually just to say look you
know we are not getting anywhere on the
politics of this let's try to take some
of the heat out of it and as I say in
the piece there's no particularly good
way to frame what's happening now for
the toy party but you could argue that
Rishi c-neck has a slight Advantage here
because he lost a leadership election
last year basically on this theme not
you know not every problem that we're
talking about now but on this idea of
fairy tales and the fact that you just
cannot over promise because you will
severely disappoint
um which you know is a good thing to
bring up in in the week of when Liz
trust took power last year and and the
49 days that followed
um you know he is able to make this case
uh people didn't want to hear it last
year still not totally sure they want to
hear it this year but it does seem that
going into party conferences and this
idea of long-termism is going to be a
theme for him and his government looking
at what he speaks on for the next 10 to
15 years
um and you know it's a hard sell to your
party because it it's not necessarily
going to win you the next election but
it is totally necessary for the country
to get back on track
thank you Kate thank you heinous and
thank you for joining us back to HB
today
next Lionel Shriver writes a column this
week about a decision by the Texan
Supreme Court to ban so-called gender
affirm and care what is gender affirm
and care and why does Lionel think it
was a good idea to ban it she joins me
now
you write in your column this week about
a decision by the Supreme Court in Texas
can you tell us about that
well there have been a number of
Republican dominated legislatures that
have passed laws Banning so-called
gender affirming care for minors it's
not making it illegal to get
uh sex change operations and medical
treatment for adults It's All About Kids
and there I have been states such as
Florida where the courts have struck
these laws down
um as a violation of so-called trans
kids civil rights
but um I observe in the column that we
deny all kinds of of
what we might call rights to Children
routinely we don't let them work in
factories why cigarettes buy alcohol
get married
or have sex with adults
and that's actually a long a much longer
list but nobody objects that it's not
fair that kids can't buy cigarettes
so I think this is a falsely framed as a
civil rights issue so I'm I'm looking at
the decision in Texas where the state
supreme court upheld the law
and that's made progressives hysterical
as usual because the default position
before this would have allowed children
to get that
gender affirming help
well there's now an entire industry
which is moving shocking numbers of
children into uh
a pathway which is almost inevitably
going to lead to uh permanent
medicalization
for the rest of their lives and often uh
life-changing
irreversible and I would say mangling
surgery
so it's not a small matter it's it's uh
it's more advanced in the US and more
culturally entrenched and
then then in the UK and while especially
Continental Europe is starting to move
away from this as is maybe not the best
way to treat confused underage people
uh the for the US it's it's become a
political cause so and I think
you know I I think we're in the midst of
a major medical Scandal that we will
look back on in much the same way that
we look back on
giving people lobotomies to to solve
their mental illness I I I just think
the results are ghastly the truth is
that most
children who are unhappy with their sex
grow out of it and the main thing that
they need to do is go through puberty
and that's what gender in affirming care
won't let you do you're put on puberty
blockers and that itself is medically
highly dubious uh can lead to Bone
thinning and it uh it inhibits mental
development the puberties it may be
confusing it may be uh
often unpleasant and you know it feels
like your body's being taken over which
it is it's being taken over by adulthood
uh but it's but it's medically vital
and uh
we started interfering with it
at scale without any real research on
what the consequences are and I think
that down the road
we're probably going to be looking at
class action suits by a lot of very
unhappy young adults who want to to come
to some understanding as to how they
were allowed to do this or why this was
done to them
um it
we don't let children make major
decisions
uh for themselves for for a good reason
they don't know what they're doing they
haven't been around long enough
uh to to make to make life-changing
decisions up of this order
and of course a lot of the problem is
parents
um so
I don't think that we should be letting
parents make these decisions on behalf
of children either
um because it's not their lives that are
at risk their ability to have children
that are risk or their ability even to
reach orgasm in adulthood
and to that point you mentioned um just
then which is the fact that if you if
you look across the world it seems
though in Europe and UK it's like you're
retreating for somebody's positions or
at least not going us all in and I just
wondered why do you think it has become
so politicized in the US
um you know is it is it political
parties is it becoming part of a culture
or what is it that's got it to that
point
I think it's the success of civil rights
in relation to everyone else it's it's
all they could find if they need you
know when you
um have been broadly successful in in
relation to race I mean not to whitewash
uh racial relations in the US but in
terms of the law
uh that that's pretty ironed out
the only the only kind of racial
discrimination that's that's legal is
affirmative action and I wouldn't do
that either
another topic
um but and and I think most of all it
was the success of the same-sex marriage
movement and and that was that stood up
in the Supreme Court so that is over so
there's nothing wrong with being gay
can't be discriminated against for being
gay so you there was just this
desperation for a new cause and I
thought it was not a coincidence that
right on the heels right on the heels of
widespread acceptance of same-sex
marriage suddenly came up this uh weird
obsession with transgenderism and
therefore a new a new population needs
protection from that bigotry
and what is the argument from those
activists who you see that ruling in
Texas and as you say are appalled by it
um did you understand it at all where
they're coming from
I I am familiar with the rhetoric uh yes
it's supposedly a matter of children's
rights uh and it's uh it's they portray
these laws as
anti-lbgtqia plus uh whereas it has
nothing to do with all those other
letters it's only about the T so it
makes it seem like this is a huge broad
side on the rights of a vast number of
people where is it concerns a much more
specific population and furthermore they
like to claim that these uh these laws
are in service of genocide
um because supposedly if you do not
provide gender referring care to people
who identify as trans then they're going
to kill themselves and there there is no
good evidence for this
the suicide rate before and after
transition among this population is
exactly the same so getting together
affirming care is not uh is not going to
keep people from killing themselves
anymore
um and furthermore
you know what well there's plenty of
propaganda out there claiming that up to
like 50 of the trans population kills
themselves this is rubbish
of if you look at one study at Tavistock
it's uh four out of 15 000. now that's
probably far too many I agree but it's
not fifty percent
yeah I suppose going to look back to the
point you made out of here which is
about um you know how you can imagine a
world where there's actually lots of
class actions in the future from those
who when they are children are given
gender affirming treatment and then for
some of the you know the permanent
features of that and could then you know
take action or be very unhappy in
retrospect do you think there's also a
portion of that group um you know people
who do you know children who are given
this who actually will get to the point
that they are happy they had it and in
those cases perhaps the gender affirming
treatment is what they need or do you
think it just shouldn't really be there
for for anyone until they reach adult
age
I agree they're probably going to be a
handful of people who are happy with the
results
uh
and a legislative solution is uh
crude tool honestly uh and
I can see why doctors would be
unenthusiastic about laws Banning
certain kinds of treatment and it means
that you can't be
as individual in your decisions but
they're not taking decisions
individually they're taking a blanket
approach so that they do give exactly
the same treatment to everyone
um and
that's what gender affirming care is all
right there is only one way to treat
this and that is to basically go through
the sex change and you know I think long
ago with this phenomenon we passed the
point where it's just you know the
people who are unhappy with the sex they
were born uh are coming out of the
woodwork and and being you know because
they're going to be more accepted this
is way beyond that this is a raging
social fad which is especially taken
hold in
um in schools and
the people who are most vulnerable to it
have many other mental health problems
uh may have social problems
maybe don't fit in uh this is an instant
way to get huge amounts of attention and
and as as as the expression has it
affirmation who doesn't want affirmation
and it means your parents are going to
be doting on you your teachers are going
to be doting on you if this uh
the way this is now constructed uh the
trans kids or Sanctified in a in the
social media at school
it's incredibly seductive so this we're
dealing with a massive social contagion
which is
possibly doing a lot of medical harm and
that's why I think legislation coming in
and saying this has to stop is a good
idea partly because the American Medical
Association and the American Pediatric
Academy is is all in with this stuff so
you can't count on the medical
establishment to put brakes on
and just final question and you
mentioned in your piece about Karina
Cohn I wonder if you could just tell
viewers about that case
now
goes by Corey
um transitioned at the age of 19 and
1994 and
he still identifies as the so-called
transsexual which is the term we used to
use
uh he accepts now that he is male and
has always been male
uh he regards his transition as
a failed fantasy
in fact he emphasizes that this is not
even about treating a mental illness it
is about
fulfilling someone's fantasy and
it's a false fantasy you can't change
sex
and I would say furthermore
what
if you do manage to change sex what have
you accomplished
just
it is not a meaningful achievement in
the world and I don't think that because
I don't believe
sex
explains Identity or should really be
the
all of your identity even if you manage
to switch signs
that's a very broad category and it
doesn't get you anywhere as a person
but this um
Corey Cohen uh is one of the people who
testified before the state legislature
uh in support of the bill and he's now
on a on a campaign
specifically to ban pediatric
transitions thank you Lionel thank you
for joining spectator TV
a year ago Liz truss was named as a
winner of the Tory leadership contest
and surely entered number 10 however she
didn't stay there for very long after
the mini budget it was really a matter
of time and she eventually resigned
before being pushed by MPS so what went
wrong and was it doomed from the
beginning I'm joined Now by James Hill
the spectator's political correspondent
and the author of her currently only
biography
James thank you for coming on spectator
TV this week quite a special week one
year since Liz truss became prime
minister of course not currently prime
minister it didn't last too long and you
co-authored a book about her time and
power and the build up to it and any
Reflections coming up to a year on
a happy transaversary yeah uh one year
um ago yesterday she entered Downing
Street
um I think after a long summer
Leadership contest and I suppose looking
back on the subsequent seven weeks that
followed her entry to learning Street
just what a stressful time they were for
the country and um a personal interest
here as well
and I suppose uh you know you've been
going over obviously the research did
for your book but also in various pieces
this week
um looking back on it do you think there
are warning signs early on
um that this was not going to go as
planned yeah I think that
there was the global economic climate of
course which was turning against low
interest rates
um but I think also we saw Tremor over
the summer months last year there was
some you know for instance policies that
were quickly dropped because they
weren't properly thought through such as
the suggestion perhaps that they were
going to have Regional pay differences
which meant that you know nurses pay
would effectively and teachers pay would
be less in different parts of the
country and that's quickly dropped so
there were kind of warning signs perhaps
that some of the policy wasn't always
kind of stress tested
um and I think that obviously they
wanted the trust government she
announced the one of the biggest
peacetime interventions in the market
with the energy package and then the
queen died and so
um it was then thereafter we thought oh
is that going to be the focus of you
know our book and Etc and
um I suppose really it was then it went
back to the economics it never really
recovered from that and as you say the
energy points are really interesting
because I think when people criticized
the trust Premiership and Trust And
nomics as it came to be known they think
about tax cuts um the tax cuts were in
the mini budget but but part of the
reason the markets were so spooked was
because so much money had already been
pleasured on energy so it was actually
spending as well as just you know this
idea of a conservatism that was mainly
tax cuts
but yeah completely and I think that you
know we would have seen a lot more of
that kind of debate but then of course
some Majesty died and so I think a lot
of awkward questions that would have
been asked about the funding of that
never got asked and then suddenly it was
all back into my budget there was this
thing rumbling along at the background
but that's ironic isn't it that one in
Britain's most favorite free marketeers
was announcing the huge energy package
and I'm sure as Kate Andrews our
colleague has written enough about there
was a certain faults with that and I
think one of the things when you listen
to Liz Trouse and of course she gave her
first interview to The Spectator after
leaving number 10 where she said you
know she she had not behaved perfectly
which I think lots of people would agree
with
um but she but she did definitely think
there were vested interests against her
um and I think that she was taken aback
that Tory MPS and some of them just
never fully got behind her
um now maybe that was naive or maybe it
says something about his MPS but do you
think that was a factor to
um that ultimately after that contest
there less mmps such as for example
um you can look at Michael Gove who I
don't know is particularly helpful to
Liz truss
um ultimately going after in the first
day of Tory Party Conference do you
think there were a group of Tories that
wanted her to fail from day one
I think they certainly didn't want to
particularly to succeed if I could put
it like that I mean obviously they would
say that you know they wanted the
country to to succeed Etc but they were
certainly I think warning signs from the
start now literature schools didn't help
herself I'd say probably by putting a
lot of these people out of the cabinet
some of the ministerial changes a bit
technical but some of the Lords for
instance getting rid of two former
Theresa May AIDS just seemed to perhaps
a little bit too vindictive and you see
which was it in terms of the kind of
government Machinery but you're right
and I certainly think there's sort of
acrimony there about how certaintory MPS
behaved certainly in a public sense and
also I think some of the triumphalism
that some of the trusts feel was
exhibited by some of those who then sort
of entered the government and took
cabinet jobs after October last year uh
was was was not necessary or
particularly edifying and so I do think
well regardless of the next election
those kind of tensions will linger
behind the surface and for now I I think
it's really hard to find anyone who
thinks Richie Seneca is not going to
lead the Tories into the next election
but of course one of the complaints you
do here oh he's very managed Nigeria Liz
trust may have got it wrong in terms of
how she went about it but she at least
identified the need for change the
stagnation facing the country so given
there is to that school of thought in
the Tory party do you think in a world
where perhaps the Tories somehow don't
win the next election and there is a
leader of the opposition contest do you
think there's anyone who could be a
perhaps not a successor to trust but at
least be arguing more for her outlook on
the economy and who should we be looking
out for yeah it's a great question just
to say the trust sites themselves you
know we refer to them as one homogeneous
group of course there's different
interpretations of what went wrong and I
was struck by an article by Simon Clark
last year talking about how they were
going to have spending restraints
spending review of reductions between
five to ten percent in Whitehall to pay
for the tax cuts
um and then that's sort of got
jettisoned and I think that he is doing
some interesting work on the Next
Generation Tories which is clearly
something conservative part of me to be
worried about the under 40s vote so I
think he will be interesting to see
whether he stands I think also any
members of her cabinet Who Remain loyal
to her will be interesting I think it
depends also on how the student
government leads office if it's Scene
goes down to a terrible defeat it'll be
interesting to see people if they reject
that kind of lessons of cynicism and say
well real trust anomics has never sort
of been tried so it's a bit to be
playing out but I think yeah Simon Clark
and I think also perhaps
um you know looking at people like
Reynolds are wanna with the conservative
growth group and what they choose to
intervene on over the next uh 12 months
or so thank you James for joining
spectator TV today
spectator contributor John Kiger writes
for this week's magazine about the
recent coup in Gabon in Africa and gives
his assessment about why many former
French colonies on the continent are now
politically volatile to tell us more
John joins me now alongside Jonathan
Griffin's Moser a security expert from
the University of Exeter
John you write in the magazine this week
about the collapse of Franco freak
though now being six former French
colonies with coups can you tell us
about the latest
well the latest one is is gabron which
is one of the Richer of the French
colonies in in Africa and it's a bit of
a surprising one because many people
hadn't really expected that to happen or
at least many French politicians haven't
expected that to happen so this is
really in a way signaling a general uh
amount of discredit that's falling on
all of the former francophone African uh
Nations that were once part of the the
French Empire Jonathan
interesting is driving this to what
extent do you think this is Auntie Fred
sentiment or is it something else I
think there's a number of things going
on here at once on the one hand on the
ground there is definitely a sense of
trying to combat the historic forces of
colonialism which these coups are kind
of framed as but simultaneously it's it
I think it reflects a degree to which
the French State itself is failing to
handle these things in part because of
the failure of the foreign Ministry and
recent reforms that macron has made over
the past two years the ambassadorial
corps and because their inability to
communicate exactly what a French agenda
is in the francophone worlds
John what's franz's relationship like
with its formal colonies and and why is
it important to still maintain influence
and Power
uh well it's a it's a long story of
course um the history of French
imperialism is in many ways rather
different to British imperialism first
of all
um it should be said I think that the
French Empire didn't really make any
money or at least it was loss making
until the late 1930s
so the French Empire was more of a
Prestige uh had it had more of a
Prestige role than than perhaps the
British Empire
um first of all because France after the
French Revolution had believed that it
had reached a higher level of
civilization and it thought that it was
appropriate that other nations should
share in that and therefore
um colonization seemed a logical thing
to happen
secondly
um the when the French lost the
franco-prussian war in 1870 Empire
seemed a great way of compensating for
that loss of national Prestige and then
once again after the second world war
um the uh occupation uh the defeat and
occupation of France meant that the
Empire seemed at the end of the war to
be a way of restoring its National
Prestige and international uh reputation
so
decolonization became a very difficult
thing to happen with so much Prestige
Weighing on it and that is one of the
reasons why a number of uh well part of
French decolonization was particularly
bloody when in indo-china or in Algeria
afterwards
I I think it's a it's a brilliant point
and just to add to it I think this
becomes part of the disconnect for 21st
century France who've used it through
this historical lens while
simultaneously
um the countries in in Franca freak and
francophony don't really understand what
the nature of the relationship is they
feel as though they're being sold a bill
of goods to be civilizational without
necessarily seeing what the benefits of
that relationship are
and Jonathan on that you mentioned some
of the changes uh recently when it comes
to
um diplomats in France
does macron want to keep these colonies
close the formal colonies
I don't know priority it's it's
difficult to say I'm not I I defer to
the experts on French politics
um I think there's little doubting the
extent to which macro has been
distracted certainly by domestic
political issues and or european
political issues we've seen his attempts
at diplomacy in the war with Ukraine
which haven't really necessarily netted
the results I think that he would like
to have seen on the global stage
um but I think at the very least from
what one hears inside
um there's a degree of
um uh apoplexy of upset of concern and
of shock uh certainly within the foreign
Ministry and in the French political
Elite level and John if France is
missing in action or no longer having
that influence there are other countries
other governments that are Keen to and
for example Russia and China can we
expect them to make inroads and what
would they have to offer
uh yes I think we can expect them to
make in ropes they've already been doing
that um China of course has invested uh
largely across the African continent and
um and so France as a traditional sort
of Provider of investment is being
overtaken uh secondly Russia uh which um
as we know with the Wagner mercenary
Armory armor uh has been uh very active
in uh in in Africa and seemed to be at
some points anyway doing a better job in
pushing back the Islamic jihadists
across the Tsar Hill more effectively
than it seemed the French were doing and
so the populations began to say well
perhaps we're better off with with the
Russians and um and Russian propaganda
of course uh highlighted the fact that
this was a a kind of post-colonial
Empire that France was running that they
shoot these nations should be fully
freed from the Yoke of French
imperialism and consequently those
populations began to say France should
leave which it has asked a number of
states have asked for France to leave
now take out its troops and they've also
asked certainly in in Niger and in other
places they've asked for the French
ambassador to be removed in a kind of
symbolic gesture of down facing France
yes Jonathan you often see those uh when
you're seeing video footage from some of
the coups you know Russian flags being
waved or references to Putin I mean I
think going back for a second to the one
of the words you used in the last
question was the was the word influence
um what's interesting to note is that in
French foreign policy the word influence
was uh highly discouraged if not
actively not allowed to be used until
the past year and so one of the legacies
as Joan referred to in terms of this
French post-colonial environment is a
sense that there was an implicit deal
that the French state would defend
um potentially dodgy rulers send in the
Foreign Legion if something went wrong
um and um if that you know and that was
that was the kind of quid pro quo what's
happened since that point and
particularly after friends failed in
Mali and has failed over the past five
years to intervene in Molly is that you
have individuals and I've spoken to
friends in Gabon and Mali in these kinds
of places who said we don't really care
who comes in as long as they they get
the terrorists and the more that the
kind of Russians through Wagner and
through its state apparatus itself push
on this Open Door the more welcome they
are made to feel by the local
populations in some of these states
so John I wondered what do you think
then are the consequences for the rest
of Europe when it comes to France's
mismanagement uh here on this issue if
it does allow as you were setting out uh
you know Russia to have this influence
uh well I I think the first thing to say
is that um
the west or and Europe in particular
have played along with the with the
French post-colonial uh game if you like
they've supported it for all sorts of
reasons because it gives um a number of
European companies access to uh to
African markets and it also very
importantly has provided to a large
extent stable regimes in a lot of that
part of West Africa or Central Africa
and the fear is of course by on the part
of the European Union in particular is
that if these states are destabilized
then that could lead to all sorts of
possible scenarios such as uh well if
it's a violent destabilization then it
could lead to mass Exodus of people and
the likely route that they would take
would be up through North Africa and
into the European Union and so there is
a good deal feel that our concern in the
EU about what could happen next
Johnson finally I wanted to can you see
a way back for France and Africa in
terms of increasing we'll use wet
influence this time and it is influenced
from the point it currently finds itself
in
um
from what I understand the nature of for
instance French institutions themselves
is in disarray no one can really decide
who's owning this agenda and who's
supposed to be
delivering that influence countering
myths and disinformation and I think
ultimately France lacks a game plan I
think you know kind of picking up on
John's point this is actually creates an
extremely unpredictable and potentially
dangerous situation not just for
francophony but for key uh British
allies in Africa not least Ghana uh not
least Nigeria so all of a sudden I think
all of this all the littoral West Africa
parts of central Africa and parts of
North Africa are now in play for Global
power competition journalism makes a
very good point there because there is a
a sense in which all of this could
become extremely contagious and France's
position as an international power could
be very seriously undermined and that
would have an impact not just on France
of course but also on on the west and
and on Britain in particular because we
have a very close military uh and to a
certain extent political relationship
with France that could be uh undermined
if France is seen by many countries
around the world as being ineffectual or
unable to manage whatever she takes on
internationally and that they could then
begin to back down and and turn away
much more from France than than has been
the case uh so far
thank you John thank you Jonathan and
thank you for joining us
the daily mails Robert Hardman writes a
letter from Balmoral in this week's
magazine and a year on from the Queen's
death he reflects on how best to
remember her he joins me now
Robert thank you for joining spectator
TV this week
um you were recently in Scotland near
Balmoral a year on from the Queen's deaf
what was the mood like
our mood was reflective but not
particularly sentimental I mean the
whole point of monarchy is is sort of
continuity
um you can't sort of spend too much time
um celebrating or commemorating you're
just going to get on with the the job
um I mean clearly uh on everyone's mind
is you know what were we doing this time
last year and obviously the the the
poignancy of being at Balmoral where the
queen died the first queen and the first
Monarch British morning to die in
Scotland
um was on people's minds but
um I I think there's a sense that um
this is an important anniversary it's
important that it's sort of logged
appropriately but at the same time and I
I kind of touch on this in my my column
in The Spectator they are very conscious
that the last 15 months the royal family
the monarchy has just been so in
everyone's faces first with the the
Platinum Jubilee last summer and then
obviously uh the death of her majesty
and then the coronation that's a lot of
sort of Royal Face Time and they're
conscious that um you know that the
public may have perhaps had enough big
Royal events so um I think there's a
very much sense it's important we
acknowledge
um the passing of emergency a year is a
key anniversary but
um you know it's business as usual
that's really interesting so in terms of
future memorials what do you think we
can expect it would be quite subdued or
as something yeah I mean I remember the
first anniversary after the death of
Diana actually and everyone was slightly
sort of oh how are we going to address
this what's appropriate and actually I
think the the general mood and the
public among the public and at the
palace as well was um you know it's it's
important to to log these moments but um
you know you can't uh dwell on it too
much you've got to move forward I mean I
think the next big anniversary
um really and there was a sort of Nod to
that in the announcement a few days ago
of the committee which I've touched on
in the piece the committee to come up
with a memorial to Elizabeth II that
committee will report back on her
Centenary which will be April 2026 so I
suspect that's if you like the the the
the the the moment when there already
will be a big sort of focus on how do we
remember this extraordinary figure I
mean I I I don't know how as I say the
piece I don't envy the committee having
to come up with an appropriate Memorial
because she has been this you know
completely unprecedented Titanic figure
in our modern history and how you do
justice to that Legacy and that memory
is is a challenge and how do you think
the queen herself would have liked it to
be marked I think she's as ever no fuss
thanks very much you know I mean it is
remarkable uh that when you look people
often compare Elizabeth II to Victoria
and and you know in in the late years of
her life Victoria was quite busy
unveiling statues of herself designing
huge
edifices to herself her her Muslim at
Windsor is is a great sort of you know
uh exercising if you like um
memorializing oneself Elizabeth II on
the other hand had absolutely no
interest in that sort of thing at all it
was really only very late in her Reign
that that she started naming things
after herself and that's because other
people asked if they could
um and I think it says it all that if
you go to pay your respects in Saint
George's Chapel Windsor to Elizabeth II
you won't find in Elizabeth II Mausoleum
that you won't find in Elizabeth the
second Chapel because she asked and
always wanted to be buried in the King
George the sixth Memorial Chapel that's
the sort of person she was I suppose
moving to the monarchy now
um a year on of course we now have the
king a new king and do you think the
monarchy looks strong it was quite
interesting polling recently um I think
there's often a lot of talk uh in the in
recent years
uh Prince of Wales took over the public
would turn against the monarchy he would
not be as popular as the queen and while
perhaps personal popularity is one thing
it doesn't feel as though it's been a
big shift or a big anti-monarchy
sentiment no I think you're absolutely
right I think more than last year has
reminded us is that actually the
monarchy is a much
stronger much more resilient
institution than many people had had
thought you were absolutely right people
used to say oh well it's all going to be
changed you know after after Elizabeth
II people said much the same actually
towards the end of Victoria's life you
know it's never going to be the same but
actually I've been the seventh it was a
very popular King the Edwardian era was
a time of of sort of General Prosperity
but you know the royal family went from
strength to strength and I think what
we've learned over the last year is that
yeah the the institution is is really
um it it's particularly in times of
turbulence I think the sort of the
general political Global uh situation
has has helped in a way because when you
think this time last year in the space
of three days we lost both our head of
government and our head of state uh
rather we gained a new head of
government lost our head of state uh and
I mean that that's for a lot of
countries that that's a you know quite a
dramatic seismic shift but Britain just
carried on because that's what the
monarchy dance you know we have this
sort of parallel State apparatus and the
politicians all shouted each other and
sort of do the The Grubby stuff and
meanwhile the the monarchy sort of holds
everything together and and and and it
sort of Don't Panic
um so I I think what we uh have seen and
what we'll continue to see is that
actually
um you know that King Charles is is
overwhelming more popular than any other
politician and the institution is uh
overwhelmingly more popular than the
alternative and don't forget even I mean
in 1952 when the queen came to the
throne was still about a fifth of the
country didn't want to monarchy I mean
you know there's a perfectly respectable
Republican argument there always has
been and there always will be but it's a
minority sport at the moment and now the
other uh question I think about
instability in the royal family was that
that makes it
um and so what would happen if you did
have as uh become the case
um you know a royal living in another
country and ultimately taking a very
different approach in terms of their
media being quite public about their
concerns do you think
Prince Harry and Meghan Markle are
particularly significant now to the
future of the royal family oh has that
in fact he died down as it's gone on
people are losing interest I I think
well I think that you look at the sales
of Harry's book shows something or
losing interest but uh but I I I do
think that it hasn't I think I think the
narrative was settled I think public
view has settled it was interesting that
uh at the start of last Autumn's
um first uh sort of noises off from Los
Angeles uh with with the Netflix series
that the Harry and Megan put out and
then we had the various interviews that
went with that then we had Harry's book
and all the interviews that went with
that it was a fairly prolonged period of
of of noise of of the solaharian Megan
agenda but it didn't really change
anything I mean the opinion polls didn't
really shift it didn't tell us anything
we didn't know already which was you
know they did not like Royal life here
they particularly hate the British press
they didn't like being part of the royal
machine they wanted a new life I think
we all know that
um I mean I think it's worth remembering
that um I I did add up the sums the
other day I mean they were a royal
couple for whatever it was six or seven
hundred days they've been a post role
couple for um you know twice that period
now there's only so much uh they can say
about Royal Life as a couple because and
I think we've probably heard it so
unless there's some you know uh unless
well the one thing I I it was
interesting reading Harry's books but
there was there was quite a lot left out
which makes you think either there's
possibly a sequel or perhaps um Megan's
got a book up her sleeves so maybe
that's coming down the track but no I I
I I think you know their new life is now
seemed settled and it's accepted by the
British public and just finally
um going back to the new king
um trip to France coming up but do you
think we can see a commonwealth trip in
the near future well uh we hope so I
mean I'm I'm told that will be one uh
there's been a lot of press speculation
about uh Kenya as the first destination
we don't I mean it hasn't been confirmed
I don't know that um but it's it's
certainly been widely tipped uh and and
he's very conscious of the fact yeah he
is head of the Commonwealth and and
that's an important uh part of his role
the Commonwealth is is sort of waiting
to to see uh what direction he obviously
doesn't have an executive role within it
but I mean it's it's currently it's
bigger than it's ever been it's
currently 56 member states I mean when
the queen took over in 52 it had eight
members
um so it's gone up uh Sevenfold
um and uh it's got a a waiting list so
it it does matter I think it sort of
felt a bit tired in recent years of
Commonwealth I think it feels like it's
sort of due for a bit of a booster so a
commonwealth tour
I'm sure there will be one by the end of
this year great thank you Robert for
joining us thanks for coming today
and finally these days Rory Stewart is
known for his podcast that he does with
Alistair Campbell often near the top of
the charts so of course we recommend
coffeehouse shots if you're looking for
a political fix
but what about his political career he
details it in a new book and I'm now
joined by Chris Mullins a former MP
himself to review Stewart's political
career and letter of political comeback
is possible
Chris thank you for joining spectator TV
this week now you've reviewed Rory
Stewart's Memoir for the book section of
the magazine what was your verdict
oh it's a very good book
uh it's an account of his 10 years in
Parliament or that and uh
Ken turbulent is in Parliament
and it's quite a
excoriated really account of our entire
political system yes and in your review
you mentioned how things didn't get off
to a great start in terms of his
ministerial career and because he
decided to have his own opinions that
did not match the governments when it
came to uh House of Lord's reform can
you tell us a bit more about that
uh well yes
um and Cameron came up with a Daft
scheme that was uh I think it was
duplicate the Dems in the Coalition uh
uh for uh I think entirely abolishing
the house uh of Lords I don't think he
meant it but that's what he was uh the
content played and Rory uh declined to
go along with it and just as he was
about to go into the wrong Lobby George
Osborne intercepts him and said if you
walk through that door that you will not
I shall make sure that you don't become
a minister in the next five years or
whatever uh and he truly walks through
the door and teacher Julie doesn't
become a minister
until not until Cameron and I was born
around out of the way
how did it shine with your own
experiences and did you did anything in
it surprised you in terms of how Rory
Stewart fan Parliament work
well the one thing that really does ring
build so he's quite an extreme case I
think he held five five ministerial
officers in four years really one one of
them the Secretary of State for
International Development but he lasted
only three months
uh
and certainly it's been a feature of
British governments now for some time
there's a constant turnover of ministers
with the result that nobody's or it's
quite rare for anyone to stay anywhere
long enough to actually achieve
something and
he's he's a man who doesn't just go into
office just in order to tick a box on
this uh CV uh he he goes in fizzing with
ideas I'm sure not all the good ideas
and uh but he he's rapidly brought down
to earth and uh
there it does have some achievements to
his name in particular when in probably
he's put in charge of the prison service
and he decides uh that I think he
actually is unwise enough to say that
he'll resign and Nessie gets knife crime
down in in prisons uh
over uh within I don't know a year or 18
months and
apparently he did we even have his word
for that but uh apparently he did but uh
so he did achieve something albeit that
his tenure was short I remember
interviewing Rory Stewart um when he
decided when he was thinking about going
for the leadership and one of the many
tourist campaigns we've had and he gave
an example I think that always stuck
with me which is effectively no I said
why do you think you would be a good
prime minister and he said there's lots
of things he knew he'd not be very good
at I think he listed ballet and being a
ballerina or something he would not
naturally be good at but he thought he
had what it took to be a good leader
um reading the book do you think that he
would have been a good prime minister
had the Tory party let them
but of course he
he is an atonian and he comes with that
sense of entitlement uh it is assumed
almost from the outset that he will
become a minister
and that in due course he will rise as
indeed he did in the rather chaotic uh
way and
there was never any chance not the
slightest chance and someone of his uh
uh energy and Views uh becoming prime
minister
and so we shall never know nor that it
was never likely that we would discover
that
yeah and it's interesting what you say
um about you know another OE auditorian
there and almost you know just thinking
you of course are going to enter
government and and climb that ladder and
perhaps being frustrated that it doesn't
happen for the period of the David
Cameron uh Governor after he chooses to
Rebel do you think it is a problem in
our political system that so many MPS uh
you know want to be ministers or is that
just natural because we just had a week
of a labor reshuffle and uh Rishi Senate
has delayed perhaps a wider reshuffle
and it does seem to occupy a lot of MPS
time just thinking about whether they
will be promoted or not
yes I'm sure that there's a lot too much
time uh wasted on who's up and who's
down and speculations about that indeed
he complains about a lot of that uh um
the gossip in the tea rooms was never
about policy it's always about who's up
and who's uh down
but there is a perfectly
satisfactory in my view alternative
career path now in politics and that is
to a bond always the case and and that
is the select committees and actually
Rory as I did did tread that path I was
chairman of the home Affairs select
committee uh on and off for four years
uh and uh he becomes chairman uh of the
defense committee I think to the
consternation of the military wing of
the Tory party uh and uh
he might have had more influence in that
capacity than he ever would have done as
a junior as a junior Minister I I no
doubt at all that I had more influences
chairman of the home Affairs committee
then I did it and at least the first two
jobs I did in government
and then just finally
um I wondered what you think you know
what next sororities do it you suggest
that he is unlikely as as you say to
become a prime minister a leader even
returned to Parliament he obviously has
a popular podcast
um I definitely that is uh you know the
sole uh best use of his talents going
forward what do you think we might be
able to expect from him in the future or
all that you would like to see him do
well who knows he appears to have a lot
of opportunities available to him uh he
he is a politician with Hinterland and
I'm occasionally asked by young people
who are Keen to get into Parliament and
Alice will go about it's my answer to
them is always the same though not
necessarily the one they wish to hear
and that is go away and do something
else first and then you might be useful
when you get in well Rory Stewart got
into Parliament at about the same age as
I did I think he I was 39 and he wasn't
far off that one way or the other
and he'd already done a lot of things
and seen along with the world uh and
now he's back in that world but and I I
think he's going to find it rather
frustrating because he's back in the
world of commentating again
uh rather than doing uh and for someone
of his energy and with so many ideas I
I'm sure he will find that frustrating
on the other hand he does have a habit
of popping up in all sorts of unlikely
places uh and uh
but the one place I predict confidently
he will not be probably not popping up
again is in domestic politics okay what
will hold you to that thank you Chris
that's it for this week
once again if you enjoy spectator TV do
subscribe to our YouTube channel just
click the Subscribe button at the bottom
of this video and tap the Bell icon so
you never miss an episode thanks again
for watching and do join us again next
week
[Music]
thank you